it's being called a humanitarian crisis
for people on this coronavirus infected
ship have already died including a
British man more may perish unless
there's an dam and her sister ship are
allowed to dock in Florida but the
governor there doesn't want them it's a
desperate time for passengers we're
hearing from the UK that there is more
illness on board that's us and um we
don't know about the Rotterdam this is a
real humanitarian crisis and we up here
we pray we implore America all the
governments around the world
please America please let us land almost
200 passengers and crew on the zaandam
are sick 9 have tested positive for
coronavirus in a bid to stem the spread
hundreds of guests were moved to the
sister ship the Rotterdam no less
uncertainty there we watch a telly spend
a lot of time watching where we are
watching TV going nowhere really my
sister and two of our friends are in
this in a cabin they have the same
amount of space for three people I'm
disappointed to hear that America or
even debating whether we should land or
not I can't understand that it's a
humanitarian rescue we're going to get
to our homes all we ask is to do do the
humane thing allow us to dock
treat us as you would like your family
to be treated President Trump is
sympathetic
we have two ships there are people that
are sick on the ship and we don't want
to be like figure the because ships you
know people turn those ships away there
was a ship as you know in a certain part
of Asia and from port to port nobody
would take it but in the meantime you
have people
that are dying on the ship or at least
very sick but they're dying on the ship
so I'm gonna out of it you know I'm
gonna do what's right not only for us
but for Humanity Florida's governor has
said he doesn't want the ill dumped on
his doorstep he may end up with no
choice but to help Debora Haines Sky
News